Tim Burton brings his vision of a dark
dreamland to the big screen and a
live-action remake of Dumbo but what did
he change from the original movie and
how does it compare to the animated
classic epic I may be lovers I'm Jan and
today I'm explaining the top 12 biggest
differences between Disney's 1941 Dumbo
movie and the brand new live-action
Dumbo film plus I'll be revealing some
Easter eggs to the original movie you
may have missed one of the biggest
changes in the live-action movie is that
there are no talking animals that means
that Dumbo's best friend Timothy Q Mouse
is no longer part of the story though we
do get a nod to him as two of the
movie's new characters Millie and Joe
have a little mouse circus and not only
as one of their mice dressed like the
animated rodents but we even see it eat
a peanut just like the first time we met
Timothy in the classic film Millie and
Joe in fact take on the role that
Timothy played as Dumbo's confidant and
champion so they stand up for Dumbo when
he's mistreated comfort him when his
mother's locked up and help him with his
flying in keeping with the filmmakers
desire to make the world feel as real as
possible
Dumbo's mother mrs. jumbo is actually
pregnant with her baby in the
live-action remake meaning there are no
baby delivering storks though there is
an Easter Egg to their animated role as
we see them in the new movie just before
we glimpse baby Dumbo for the very first
time like in the original mrs. jumbo
protects her young son from bullying and
threats which once again lands her in
elephant jail though on this occasion
the filmmakers up the stakes
making the consequences for shielding
her son even more dire though they also
add a modern twist to her venture
reunion with her little one there's no
chorus of female elephants to criticize
and ridicule Dumbo this time but he does
get more than enough of that from some
of the circus workers crowd and even
Danny DeVito's ringmaster at first
talking stalks elephants and mice aren't
the only creatures cut from the
live-action film also can do the crows
who helped young Dumbo fly and their use
of feathers and psychology to encourage
his aerial abilities is taken over by
Joe and Millie the crows absence from
the new movie is hardly surprising given
they've been heavily criticized as
racist stereotypes of African Americans
there is a little Easter Egg to their
fame
seong when I see an elephant fly though
when the dreamland ringmaster introduces
Dumbo's act with a slight variation on
the following lines from the crows most
of the live-action films new characters
a human but there is one notable new
animal addition a monkey who just like
the other animals never talks and is
completely computer-generated the new
CGI primate reminds me of the popular
real-life one that featured in the night
of the museum movies and like that
capuchin monkey this new mischievous
monkeys role is to add some comic relief
which it does plenty of by performing
both Shakespeare and damsel in distress
routines as part of the circus and also
by popping up in some surprising places
so the monkey near death just for
emergencies just like the star of the
animated movie the computer-generated
lead of the live-action film was
entirely adorable and despite the many
tweaks to the airborne elephant story
such as the origin of his name and how
we find out he can fly Dumbo's character
remains as heartwarming and moving as
before which means his adventures will
likely break your heart before finally
putting it back together again and the
film's core messages of self-belief and
the differences strength not weakness
are still very much there indeed they're
further highlighted by Dumbo's adopted
human family the classic movie last for
mere 64 minutes compared to the new
films almost two hour runtime so it's
hardly surprising this plenty of new
material and Tim Burton's reimagining of
the tale in fact the scene where Dumbo
flies down from a burning building at
the end of the original film is
recreated about a third of the way into
the live-action movie and is really the
jumping-off point for a whole new
strands the flying elephant story which
is now set just after the first world
war rather than during the Second World
War when the animated film was made in
another change this time Dumbo doesn't
get drunk on champagne and hallucinate
pink elephants however there is a
gorgeous version of that memorable
moment as a circus performers make
bubble elephants that multiply and dance
there's even a suggestion that the new
baby Dumbo gets mesmerized watching the
performance as he nods along to the
music with an entranced look on his face
when it comes to songs Dumbo takes a
leaf out of Disney's live-action
Cinderella rather than their recent take
on Beauty and the Beast with only one of
the full songs from the animation making
it into the new film actress Sharon
Mooney who plays a circus mermaid gives
a sweet performance of baby mind the
beautiful lullaby that accompanies an
emotional scene between Dumbo and his
mother and you should listen out for
some nice Easter eggs to the animations
other famous songs including a nod to
pink elephants on parade as well as
Danny DeVito singing a couple of lines
from Casey jr. Plus during the credits
you'll hear different versions of those
songs again as well as a jazzy
instrumental of when I see an elephant
fly with the lack of talking animals the
human characters in Burton's movie
become much more important Danny DeVito
is great as a struggling circus owner
max Medici who has a bigger role in the
new film than the original ringmaster
initially Medici wants to hide Dumbo's
large ears from the circus going public
and although he echos some of the
animated elephants mean words and locks
up to mrs. jumbo he turns out to be a
much more obviously sympathetic
character than his animated counterpart
that he tries to do the best he can for
his large circus family of strongmen
mermaid snake charmers and more the
addition of Michael Keaton's ba
VanDerveer is a major change in the
original animation where although the
chorus of elephants are incredibly nasty
too Dumbo and the tormenting boys are
also horribly cruel there's no one
standout villain in contrast Keaton's
ruthless entrepreneur whose desperate to
buy Dumbo circus so he can exploit the
miraculous pachyderm and make a mountain
of money adds a new and interesting plot
to this version it also takes us to
dreamland a theme park that VanDerveer
sees as a future of entertainment but
which has a much darker side something
else the filmmakers wanted to achieve
with the human characters was that Dumbo
story would be a way for them to reflect
on their own situations so for example
former circus star and wounded War
veteran halt farriers relationship with
his children parallels the relationship
between Dumbo and mrs. jumbo because
just as young Dumbo is trying to
reconnect with his mum so to halt and
his children are trying to put their
family back together after being forced
to part by the
or million Joe also know how it feels to
have lost a mother which adds an extra
dimension to the bond they form with
Dumbo although the human characters are
a neat way for the filmmakers to
differentiate this version of Dumbo from
the original they're an area where the
new movie can fall a little flat even
though they get more screen time than
their animated counterparts like Timothy
Q Mouse generally they don't make the
same impact the issue isn't the cast
list which is suitably impressive
including Colin Farrell Eva Green and
Alan Arkin the thing is that there are
almost too many new human characters to
the point that they're pretty thinly
drawn still this is Dumbo story and
there's still a lot of sweetness tears
and joy to be found in this beautifully
designed world now it's your turn to let
me know which is your favorite Dumbo
movie tapping the top right and after
you've cast your vote you'll be able to
see the results if you enjoy deep dive
theories and behind-the-scenes secrets
about your favorite Disney movies be
sure to subscribe and hit the bell to
get all my new videos thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers